welcome to this video Arnie's senior
from Brazil and he's playing a 4 no
that's cool okay let's see now I'll just
just play classical fashion a 4 I mean
it's not not great but quite often if
you play reversed type of opening like
like this it's um it's not good terrible
just place them yeah the modern or pills
defend something like that answer well
if for it's not great but it doesn't
hurt much so let's see playing them with
c6 just controlling the center yeah poor
should up go hmm yeah I'm always tempted
by that gaining space in the center
especially if the bishop is on be too
hmm now on he might play be formed if I
am retreat to see some yeah well it's
not it's not so terrible i can play p5
even ok yeah that one of course also
possible
so should I play b5 yeah I need to fight
against the night so no use in delaying
that
yep easy move for once
yeah I think this should be should be
about equal I don't really think that
there is so much going on Queen to b4
that's a bit bit weird really playing
with peace play okay yeah well why we
can play Queen B 5 I thought this is
this is weird because of the should be
seven but of course he can he can play
Queen a 6 I had to forgotten about that
who came what now
yeah but I'd like to do is play be 5v5
and then depending on this answer there
are ideas like rookie six rupees sixes a
general idea our queen aid though well I
think this should be should be
comfortable for like he doesn't really
have any major ideas yeah this is just
bad i think what are you doing now
Knight a5 found this if he go if I go
rook e6 he has Queen B 7 yeah this seems
entirely completely unfair that he has a
way to save the bees night a5 Bishop c8
okay he retreated instead yeah probably
a wise decision so what now
should I take Jim problem
then I wait I can't play I just only saw
it now I can play be four and we should
be five winning the d3 pawn I mean it's
not the end of the world for white
because he's got the c-4 square so
there's some slight compensation for
that I actually attack c5
okay but if it takes I can play but
should be six this is strong he
obviously does not listen to my comments
which is a good thing he's not the NSA
but I can I'd see him Queen well Quincy
one I thought that just gives me too
much activity thoughts on IG for coming
let's not spend time on that he has no
way to defend f2 wow this looks this
looks like a disaster white forfeits due
to disconnection yeah well maybe this is
some the fitting the fitting end to this
game which started a four was already
suggests some weirdness he disconnected
well I think white is busted here right
yeah minus three comsys yellow he should
shoes you should just trade Queens him
this is not great but you can try to
defend because in this pawn structure
I've given up the c-4 square and this
means it's not so easy to move the pawns
all right black is better of course but
you can fight with some reason with some
reasoning not sure maybe you shouldn't
have played c3 it should be really equal
just a few just retreat to the two at
some point Queen a7 for instance what
what am i doing moving the Queen away
probably here it's not much happening he
has the FR i did so close that probably
it's very dry now draw is just wrong I
mean it's equal there's so many pieces
on the board and there are ways to play
it's not exactly draw much but hard to
make progress alright thanks for
watching